hey guys welcome to the Rubin report I'm
still Dave Rubin we've got writer and
BuzzFeed er Louis Heitzman with us and
comedian and Renaissance man john
fugelsang with us and let's get right to
it john boehner he's the Speaker of the
House he's a very very tan man and guess
what he is suing President Obama that's
right he has had it with these executive
actions that basically the Republicans
have forced President Obama to take
because they won't allow him to get any
legislation to his desk to sign and now
they're saying he's overreaching so
Boehner is actually forming a lawsuit to
sue the president over this and a
President Obama's not too happy about it
and we've got some video you know the
suit is is fun but what I've told
Speaker Boehner directly is if you're
really concerned about me taking too
many executive actions why don't you try
getting something done through Congress
the majority of American people want to
see immigration reform done we had a
bipartisan bill through the Senate and
you're gonna squawk if I try to fix some
parts of it administratively that are
within my authority while you are not
doing it okay so just to be very clear
what's happening here the Republicans
are not giving him any legislation to
sign so he's trying to take power with
which is within his right even though
I've talked a lot about how I'm not for
the executive actions and I believe in
separation of powers and all that but
they're pretty much giving him no choice
he seems pretty pissed there for Obama
that's actually pretty pissed don't you
think I agree well he's right that it's
a stunt and it's got nothing to do with
him it's all about the fact that John
Boehner knows how deeply the tea party
hates him and this is nothing more than
a craven plea to the tea party to
respect him by doing something
disgusting Obama has had significantly
fewer executive orders of the President
Bush which never bothered anyone
yeah and it's literally like 20% of what
yeah yeah you know this is but this is
Agent Orange is whole thing he's got
nothing going he has no legislative
agenda no legislative agenda whatsoever
and this is why when they want to talk
about Obama having a low approval rating
well Congress has a lower approval
rating than committee
chlamydia is like at five because the
solid 15 fun getting there as opposed to
John Bainer so this is all look when
they were voting last year on who the
Speaker of the House should be there
were a signal several rather conspicuous
protest votes against Speaker Boehner
Louie Gohmert actually voted for for
what's-his-face the lunatic Ted Cruz no
not Ted Cruz thing the alan west what
you lunatic they're selling questa soap
it's his Thorazine flushed itself down
the toilet well he's out of a job was
out of a job then yeah Gohmert voted for
a guy who had been voted out of Congress
to be the Speaker of the House over
speaker Bainer he knows how deeply
unpopular he is that his biggest ally
was Eric Cantor who wanted his job this
is John Bainer desperation showing
through and it's not gonna make the Tea
Party like him anymore and that really
didn't work out for Eric Cantor so
before we get into too much of the
political minutiae of this did you know
that they could even sue the president
doesn't it seem like the worst possible
like our governments so dysfunctional
and by the way you could sue the
president well here's one I'm seeing I'm
seeing Boehner being desperate I'm still
Obama being angry and I feel like the
best way to solve this is with reality
television show I would absolutely
support a stunt like that if I could
watch it play out on TV yeah is what do
we do about this because this is
something we talk about every week on
this that just the branches of
government no longer work that Obama's
being forced and it works if you work it
not to sound like a man in a room but
they work if you work at it right but
what with the construct that we have now
just with it with the Republicans sort
of being held hostage by the tea party
like it's just nothing's working
so what do we do to make this work
instead of going to IDI otic lawsuits
and forcing the president's hand to do
things that a lot of people don't want
him to do in that kind of thing well I
mean this is openness making it work
that's why he's doing this the American
people don't want to sit around and you
know complain about the government they
want the government to do stuff for them
but it is in the interest of the GOP to
make government as weak as possible they
serve the CEOs the struggle in our
country has never been conservative
versus liberal it's aristocracy versus
democracy and it is in the interest of
the upper 1% of the upper point oh one
percents evil half to keep government
from working and I find it interesting
the same people who are trying to weaken
here are complaining that other
countries of you are government is a
weak
I love that line I saw you tweeted it
earlier it's you know exactly what they
do they want they're getting exactly
what they want they want the gridlock
they want nothing to happen because if
government works that means democracy
works and if democracy works that means
the people are gonna run this country
and that is not in the interest of these
are the vassals of the Koch brothers so
going to your reality show point should
we have more cameras around what's going
on really is do you remember during the
Obamacare debate even President Obama
said we will have this all open to
everybody and will air at all and c-span
of course none of that happened I think
the Democrats don't want it just as much
as the Republicans don't want it so
really shouldn't we have not that has to
be a reality show we're voting people
off although I think that's pretty good
idea but shouldn't we have just more
cameras around so some of this stuff is
actually true or at least a really well
made a Netflix documentary I mean that
changes mine on Romney if that amount
before the election things would have
gone very different was about an old
baseball glove and that would have been
more interesting now for you you're
right though III think the Supreme Court
should be on television I think student
I think classrooms I think public school
classrooms should be on the Internet
I think executions should be televised
we're paying for it I will if you
televised executions you'd see the
numbers on death penalty flip overnight
so you think it would go yeah I think is
so sadistic it might actually go people
who go to church and call themselves
Christians despite the fact that Jesus
quite clearly spoke out against killing
the sinner he never mentioned birth
control never mentioned abortion never
mentioned gay people did speak out about
killing the center rather specifically
if these people saw the murder that
their tax dollars pay for and by the way
I like that they don't consider it
murder if the state does it doesn't get
more big government as strapping a guy
to a table and poisoning him to death
right and doing it in front of viewers
yes although sometimes the guy that's
actually doing the poisoning or the
electrocution or whatever they doesn't
even know because they have them by
nichole taxpayers have a right to see as
much of what they pay for as possible
that doesn't jeopardize national
security yeah all right televised case
extra so they know what they're missing
out on
we do that's the next step in the gay
rights movement is televised gay sex
sorry John you guys are looking at the
wrong porn sites you don't know all
right well you've given me a good segue
here because let's talk about Jesus and
the gays because Elton John has come out
and said that Jesus would be down with
the gays that's right we've got a little
video from the interview but you ever
think the church I mean the church do
you think it should allow its clergy
safe sex clergy to get married of course
and and and and I don't see why Catholic
priests have to be celibate it's crazy
you know these are old and stupid things
and the church hierarchy might be you
know up in arms about it the
traditionalist but times have changed we
live in a different time China if Jesus
Christ was alive today I cannot see him
as the Christian person that he was and
the great person that he was saying this
could not happen
he was all about love and compassion and
forgiveness and trying to bring people
together and that is what the church
should be about love and compassion and
all that good stuff could that be what
Jesus was really all about Louis I I
would say so yes I would also say I have
to tell you the thing that struck me
most about this story was Elton John
saying he wanted to have a small wedding
that was like Jesus comments I was
mostly shocked by him saying that he
wanted to have a quiet small wedding and
not like a hologram of Jesus actually
blessing the ceremony which is what I
would expect from him right that's
actually really funny cuz you know he
runs the big Oscar party here in West
Hollywood after the Oscars and it's huge
and over the top and ridiculous but I
just ya know I mean I I absolutely agree
with him though and I think that there
are plenty of Christians who have the
same comments the same points about
Jesus's teachings and how they certainly
match what we hear about from the
religious right on a regular basis yeah
so John this is your wheelhouse stuff
this is one of your favorite well you
know look I think Jesus would object to
Elton John's setlist in concert for the
last time what's with the new stuff I
like the Leon Russell out but do I have
to wait three hours to get to your song
good God
well of course he's right I mean he's
wrong about one thing that Jesus was a
Christian person Jesus lived and died a
Jew yeah
but he's exactly right about it
homophobia is an insult to God there is
no passage of the Bible say this to your
trolls well yeah there is no passage of
the
you can use to justify any kind of LGBT
discrimination nunny all follow
Leviticus and Romans isn't about gay
people I know all the verses very well
there's nothing in the Bible to justify
it so he's exactly right about that he's
also right about the Catholic Church and
celibacy the cat the first Pope st.
Peter was married and all the priests
and Pope's and bishops were married for
over a thousand years
it wasn't until Pope Innocent the second
and 1139 AD main celibacy the law to
keep priests and popes from leaving land
and wealth to their children so that
laws not because sex was bad not because
Christ was a bachelor but because the
church was greedy
which means married priests are
technically the conservative point of
view that's quite fascinating actually
it's all greed based so dealing the
church in the long term actually kind of
screwed itself with all this crazy sex
stuff and the repression and the gay
stuff that it worked for a while for
many hundreds of years it worked but now
we're getting to the point where that
stuff doesn't fly anymore and it's
actually turning people more against
religion of course it always backfires I
mean look at Italy there was a country
where because of the Catholic Church
being there they had no contraception
they had very few teachings of any of
that and the abortion the abortion rates
skyrocketed the death from abortion were
crazy because they had no teaching about
how to have proper contraception I mean
these things the more draconian the laws
are the harder it is to kind of have a
normal safe life affects the Teresa
opposed divorce you know and and again
birth control not in the Bible this is
the same this rule is the same reason
why we have the laws of Leviticus it's
not about holiness it's about keeping
your tribes numbers up and they're
becoming a third world religion and
they're going into the third world and
saying your poverty is a gift from God
you'll get your reward in heaven you
can't be devout less you're pumping them
out and the more poor people you have
who are superstitious and ignorant to
keep everything more babies the more the
more size your flock has and the more
you can fleece said flock and it's back
it still works in a third world its
backfires big-time in the first world
yeah so none of it's biblically
supported right not that they really
care what's biblically supportive that's
about you see
do you think when Elton John says
something like this does any heart or
mind get changed there because the
people that are on board you you think
that actually affects us so somebody
that you think is a believer you think
can actually hear that message burdens
on them to explain why Christ would
oppose same-sex marriage when he never
said a thing against gay people and I
could bore you with you know passages
that I think prove that Jesus had a
pro-lgbt attitude the story of the Roman
centurion who's please come to my house
to heal my slave and the Apostles were
so angry but what do we know about the
Romans historically they brought their
teenage boy lovers on the road and the
Greek the word is a slave it spice for
beloved boy so that explains why the
apostles were so furious at Jesus that
he and why would a Centurion of the
again I'm taking the story literally
it's yeah that's that's how they wanted
why would a Centurion of the Imperial
European occupying army seek out a
homeless local Jewish mystic faith
healer to come into his home to heal a
common slave it explains why the
Apostles were so outraged because Jesus
essentially blessed a gay Union yeah
John's taking the highbrow stuff Jesus
had abs that's proof he with a low brow
that was and also yeah let's just do
that more reality television more
fixation on Jesus's ABS yeah Jesus makes
Buddha really insecure
alright so last thought on this so you
know this new pope has been kind of down
with the gays and he's so sort of it's
still you're getting a lot of repression
but a little bit are you both not at the
same time so but but basically he kind
of has said let's get away from talking
the talk better than any other pope I'm
waiting for the walk to get walked yeah
I assume yes the same thing I mean I
think that it's easy to kind of be happy
to make these statements that go viral
on Facebook but I don't know if he
actually has I mean he hasn't carried
through with any of these thoughts in
any meaningful way yeah all right I love
the guy and I hope he gets a really good
food taster yeah you hopefully will Pope
can you can you like this on you
completely I saw Godfather three days I
know how this ends yeah all right let's
talk about Facebook have you heard of
this monstrosity this giant company that
is stealing all your data you signed up
for it though so is that stealing I'm
not so sure well you know what they're
doing with your data they are actually
doing bizarre scientific tests
to depress you yeah that's right we've
got some info for one week at early 2012
Facebook changed the content mix in the
newsfeed of about 700,000 users some
were shown a higher number of positive
posts while others were shown more
negative posts the study found that
users were shown more negative content
were slightly more likely to produce
negative posts users in the positive
group responded with more upbeat posts
okay so we all talked about this all the
time of the data and that we just give
this stuff away and we didn't ever read
the Terms of Service and we click YES on
everything but now they're actually
manipulating things to alter our mood
I'm pretty sure nobody signed up for
that I I hate Facebook I talk about it
constantly on this show that negative
things make people feel negatively yes
it is crazy the theory that negative
things make other negative things crazy
how do you know if you're one of the
subjects if you're already depressed all
the time like me like I don't understand
they probably would have left someone
like you out of their algorithm I mean
I'm depressed by my distant cousins
making me play candy crush saga so I
really know how much worse it could get
okay so should anyone be upset by this
really though because we sign up for
these things we know we don't read the
Terms of Service right it's a 50-page
thing that you just scroll down and
click YES on and then they're doing this
to us but it's a free service so do we
have any right even to be upset we have
a right to be upset that they showed us
things that we're depressing when we
were using their free service that we
signed up for we have a right to be
upset but do we have any recourse
against them no it's it's their baby
right so some people are trying to get
together and pull some kind of lawsuit
but I'm sure that's not gonna go any if
you go to a party voluntarily and the
music bums you out you're welcome to
leave yeah I mean I've driven most sites
do these things you know where they have
like two different versions for
different users and that CNN does
different headlines for example to see
what people click on more you know
they're all testing us yes it's just
probably giving you more of your high
school friends having babies to depress
does really bummed me out but you know
it's my choice to be on Facebook and to
for whatever reason to be friends with
people I haven't seen in 12 years yeah
find that the positive news actually
depresses you more than the negative
news you know to me like if there is
some theory on this that if you keep
seeing your friends doing all this cool
stuff like people just by Instagram
everyone's food looks better than it
actually is
and you think everyone's eating better
food than you so do you ever get more
depressed by the positive things that
you see people doing than just the
people who are suicidal well when it
comes to Instagram I'm really torn
between pictures of other people's food
and pictures of girls feet on a beach in
front of bodies of water sort of torn
between those two polarities but uh you
know I believe it was Nietzsche who said
we hate it when our friends become
successful
no that was Morrissey yeah I mean no I I
mean if it's positive news in the world
great yeah it's positive news for my
friends if their friends that I love
it's great if their friends that I
secretly hate then you know that's my
problem in it yeah cuz I mean that's a
that's a good theory I like that I feel
like if Facebook just had more posts
hashtag blessed they'd probably would be
more homicidal by the end of the day are
you guys with me in the general thing
like I just had it with Facebook I just
don't like anything that it's about now
I only have a fan page so I'm not
involved in in all the minutiae of
what's going on with the feed and
everything but just this connectedness
is I'm just completely over no I
disagree I love it I love knowing the
names of my cousin's hideous children I
love being able to get back in touch
with the same guys who called me Fagin
through gum in my hair in high school
yeah you know being able to do that and
but not your later hair than them being
able to being able to get you know which
brat pack member quizzes are you ten
times a day is enriched me culture no I
mean I like Facebook I use Facebook as a
promotional tool as a comedian you know
I have a fan I have a fan page I have I
have the old profiles I used to have and
then I have a private page for my family
where I just post baby pictures so my
cousins don't think I'm a leftist
monstrosity hi so you know I get a lot
you guys have what you put into it and I
don't really get so sucked into it that
I'm giving my email information way to
apps and things like that
no Facebook apps no Facebook hacks
science stuff there you go so you're
doing it in a very controlled kind of
way how do you
management first of all check your
facebook fanpage privilege because not
all of us have that option I say that we
all do like gross this really no I mean
I I'll of Facebook in the same way that
I love Twitter you know it's a mixed bag
and I feel like it's a great promotional
tool and you you use it as you need to
use it and you block people willingly I
mean I have a bunch of I have this
problem where a lot of old women follow
me on Facebook we don't really know why
but they do yell at me and chris is my
language you talk about the Golden Girls
a lot I do we don't we still don't
really know where they came from but I
do have a Facebook problem with
harassment yeah and I just make a joke
out of it because I feel like it's a
best way to handle this Facebook is much
better with harassment than Twitter
though because on face yes you actually
have to show your name and identity and
most people don't go to the trouble of
putting together an alias as they do on
Twitter on Twitter these these are these
coward child men it can come out and
call you names yeah yet they're
protected by their own anonymity that
doesn't happen on Facebook I have a
policy the Twitter policy which is I
won't fight with an egg if you're just
like a Twitter egg I will not well you
fight with them and no I don't I retweet
I retweet the really brilliant stuff
they're really funny stuff and they're
really mean dumb stuff yeah and you know
check their check their follower count
cuz if it's someone with 12 followers
you know I used to see Keith Oberman
getting these lame Wars yeah these guys
with these eggs with 12 I'm like Keith
its Twitter there's girls here what are
you doing what are you fighting like
this but I honestly III think that it
can be very instructive and I think that
you can use those debates as a way of
letting someone else hang themselves
creatively yeah alright so final thought
on this is there anything that would get
you to the point where you'd be willing
to actually get off Facebook it like so
if you know they're doing experiments on
you is there any point with which it
would just you know the straw and the
camel's back just say no I'm just gonna
be really honest about it yeah your says
I'm so promoting my stuff on Facebook
like there's it's gonna I'm gonna say
yeah but they do anything with all this
information even if you're hiding it to
the best you can invest in Union Carbide
they could be paid yeah they could be
you know funding baby seal clubbing
trips I mean there's lots of things to
get done that was a cover I hate seal I
have to he hates everything you know
lots of things that could be done
where I'd want to withdraw my membership
but I I think that they're smart
businessmen they create a fun service it
is a great way to keep in touch with
relatives without having to actually see
them and I think in that sense it's
gonna be around for a long time yeah all
right there you go let's talk about
cupcakes they are the newest hottest
controversy we always have a controversy
about something that used to be okay now
it is cupcakes a seattle school is
banning cupcakes in elementary schools
why are they doing it well we've got
some info for you basically they don't
want kids to be fat that's sort of the
short of it so they are allowing food
can only be served at three classroom
celebrations per year the decision was
based on nutritional factors and
economics it's not healthy for a cupcake
party to be thrown for every student on
their birthday because if you're in a
class of thirty that means you're having
30 cupcakes a year which is basically
one cupcake every ten days I don't think
it's that bad and not all families can
afford to send treats to school for a
birthday celebration leading some
students to feel slightly left out so I
guess maybe that one has some validity I
think making some kind of economic
arguments or two makes sense but the
idea that we're taking away these
companies I know I get it the sugar we
talk about
yeah the wings are all rubbish yeah
you're not on it I mean I get it I get
all the stuff when we talk about high
fructose corn syrup and all the horrible
stuff we're eating and everyone's
getting diabetes and all this stuff I
get all that the reason go
the reason is teachers unions know
better than anyone you don't give rooms
of 30 kids expect to do your job it's
hell it's hell yeah
so that's really what's going on yet
they want to control those kids and
screaming little imps it's horrible it's
disgusting they're all hopped up on
crack no you can says the one father on
the panel well yeah I mean I think it's
interesting that they said in article
you know be encouraged parents to bring
in other things like erasers which is
hilarious to me I guarantee if I growing
up had had a pair of bring in something
that wasn't edible I would have found
the way to eat it I mean the entire
point of going to school is having
birthday parties like nights a week and
in fairness also a lot of kids are born
in summer so it's not thirty now I was
born on Labor Day and my
the Virgo which means I'm a lot of work
but I'm worth it and and the fact is
that when my first day of school in
first grade was my birthday
and I told the teacher it's my birthday
and she thought I was lying I never got
a cupcake party it wasn't until months
later she found out I've been telling
the truth and I had a retroactive one
and I was reparations thanks a lot to me
but know it there are other practical
ways you can give bringing grapes you
know like you can do other things for a
party you can sing a song or do
something special to not teach kids for
20 minutes right so you're sort of down
with the general idea this I really
believe they do not me it's that it's
not it's not because of the nutritional
factor they're not afraid that one
cupcake party or even 30 cupcake parties
is gonna cause obesity I'm more worried
about what the kids are eating at home
low-income families can't afford a
healthy meal you know I was in
Mississippi making this film for PBS and
and you know in so many communities
there's no grocery stores in rural
America and poor families get all their
food from the dollar store or the gas
station right which is all processed
that it's not this that's not yeah
that's not the school's responsibility
this is all about sugar and hopped up
little crank heads okay so if it is
about that don't you still think you
lose something by not having that like
if I think back to my elementary school
days those were great like they'd
somebody who come in with the cupcakes
everybody like you lose something if we
don't let kids celebrate the way a kid
guess what their sugar when they're
adults to so I get it you're trying to
set some sutures that have to deal with
that right so I get it but don't you
think they're losing something like
you're just losing something about
growing up if you can't eat frickin
cupcakes in school yes the kids will
find a way to eat cupcakes anyway I mean
I'm not saying I guess that's a terrible
argument cuz that's kind of what people
who are against control say but I just
feel like cupcakes are gonna happen
regardless maybe have one party a month
for everyone born in that month and you
have a condensed cupcake and you can
have it a you know at 3 p.m. instead of
having in the middle of the day I'm just
gonna get solutions here so we don't the
stop eating cupcakes right so you want
the cupcakes the teachers union would
say you know what give them a cupcake as
they're leaving school
I'm happy to see one small tiny victory
for a teacher's union somewhere in
America but I think a very practical
solution is at the end of every month
you have you take one hour at the end of
every month and have your cupcake party
for all the kids who had a birthday that
month that way the poor kids aren't
singled out for more shaming if they
can't bring in cupcakes you just do for
every kid who had a birthday in March
we're doing it and we're doing it in the
30 minutes before we put you on the bus
right that doesn't bode well for the bus
drivers know it so then they have a very
powerful union to compare cheek
appearance and deal with the sugar high
and right they can just lock them in the
basement and do what they want with them
you guys think we're gonna ever have
like a bounce back against this health
conscious thing that we have going on
right now because we are talking about
it so much that I do fear that we're
gonna have this weird thing where
suddenly everyone's gonna want to eat
awful what you fear it I feel like it's
just the best normal scenario obviously
that's a problem too but I feel like we
we might be a little too short at times
I don't know I'm not raising a child I'm
also making my own poor dietary choices
right now so I don't know but isn't it
like the done thing as you just said
like it's to me so you know every time
we're suing somehow the gun sales go up
yes and I think that's partly what's
happening here we keep telling people to
eat well and then everything shows that
they're eating worse is there some weird
what is it with the only way to stop a
bad man with a cupcake is a good man
with a it's amazing what an equaliser
type-2 diabetes can be you know and I
think unfortunately it's gonna you know
if from me as a child that took sitting
next to my grandfather with lung cancer
holding his hand when he died for me to
know I was never gonna eat sick take
cigarettes yeah and I think a lot of
kids are gonna have to see the suffering
of their parents and grandparents from
having an unhealthy lifestyle to really
realize it and even then they might not
because foods a drug and comfort food is
a really nice way of phrasing something
but what it really is is unhealthy
habits and it's not about changing diet
is about changing habits and that's a
lot harder yeah that's why we talked
about this on the show because we're
trying to get a little a little
information across I of course I'm gonna
still eat cupcakes openly and freedom
according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics there are about 3.6 million
people who are at or below
the minimum wage they're working at or
below the minimum wage and upworthy
created a couple graphs on this that I
thought were pretty interesting so let's
take a look okay so who works at the
minimum wage teenage boys 10% I think
that makes sense you get your first job
you're cutting grass you know doing
other newspapers there's some newspaper
boys that's what I did
adult women this one's crazy at minimum
wage almost half of those people are
women adult women teenage girls 14
percent adult men 27.5% now here's the
fascinating part so 34 percent of these
people who are at minimum wage have some
college or an associate's degree that
seems incredibly high 7 percent have a
bachelor's degree or higher 28% less
than high school so that I think makes
some sense and 31% are high school
graduates so there's there's some
interesting numbers here some I think
kind of surprising and some not too
surprising but the education one is the
scary one to me I mean the people that
are going to college and still working
minimum wage this is a scary number
right yeah I mean stay in school you can
end up working a minimum-wage job it's
not the best encouragement right that's
not that's not helping no the scariest
number which wasn't listed on those
graphs is that I believe it's 56 percent
of minimum wage earners are full-time
workers and more than half of minimum
wage earners provide most of the income
for their households yeah we have to
decide if we're gonna live in a society
where a person can work full-time and
still live below the poverty line but
these graphs here show were very
valuable because one of the most
insidious arguments against raising the
minimum wage which a decent society
would do it's at least we could do after
destroying unions which built the middle
class is that they're all kids doing
summer jobs their starter jobs and
that's enough it's simply not the case
so I assume both you guys are on board
this Seattle idea of the $15 minimum
wage
I thought about two cupcakes sure what
suggest you want to pay people in
cupcakes going back to our earlier well
yeah but I mean that's a separate issue
the week we're taping this of course is
the week that la bete California just
raised their minimum wage from $8 to 9
and Cisco its 1070 for an hour and if
you adjust for productivity
and inflation the minimum wage today
should be 21 dollars an hour now
Australia raised theirs to $16 an hour
an unemployment went down right it's
gone up since then because of mining
closures but all the same doomsday
predictions were made and they were all
proven false every time they've ever
tried to raise the minimum wage going
back to Henry Ford instituting the $5 a
day wage for his workers on the line at
the 4th Factory and they've all said
this will crush the economy kill jobs
it's never true because if your
employees have more money they are
spending more money in your community
and it drives the economy the middle
class are the job creators and if we're
all gonna be low wage slaves eventually
there will not be high enough walls for
the 1% in their gated communities yeah
you know we did a story in December
about literally at Walmart because they
pay their employees so poorly they were
taking donations at Walmart for their
own employees for tools well that's the
thing with Walmart is its price is so
nice you pay for them twice you know cuz
they get subsidized there are some
stores where up to 80% of Walmart
workers are on snap or some kind of
public assistance so you're paying for
those low prices when you're there
buying your non american-made crap and
you're paying for it again every April
when you're paying your taxes and
subsidizing and the the 16 airs of the
Walmart fortune control as much wealth
as the bottom 40 million of Americans
that's disgusting and it's not
conservative and it's not sustainable
and it's not same yeah so when we hear
all those numbers what are we supposed
to do because it's not changing this is
all getting worse what do you think we
can do actually to change the trend
you're asking for an actual solution
like some kind of solution yeah I mean
job are a lot of logic into the argument
I feel like is rare yeah no I mean I
think raising the minimum wage makes
absolute sense I mean you have facts and
figures to back that up with which is
you know always made a movie about it so
that's that's unfair you came prepared
yeah I mean is there really a question
about this that I think we're all in
agreement here yeah why do you think
women make so much less than men still
you know even in the white shirt
even in the White House this week they
showed that the average man that's
working in the White House right now I
think makes eighty seven thousand
dollars per year and the average woman
is making about seventy seven thousand
dollars now I get it there's people at
different jobs there might be some
reason but why even now is it still
women or make it less it's almost like
there's like a disparity between what
men make women make and on a broader
scale so it's not just the White House I
would say it's not just the White House
yeah I would say it's a national problem
it might be unfair to the white house
you know women make less because that's
what everyone's agreed to yeah and when
everyone stops agreeing with it it'll
change but you know you want a real
solution get money out of politics I'm
with Secretary Rice on this is the only
way you're gonna start it find a way to
get money out of politics look I'm not a
liberal I'm an Eisenhower Republican
okay and why was the middle class so
strong in the 1950s everything
Republicans hate now strong Union
involvement do yourself a favor look at
some 1956 Eisenhower re-election posters
it's all about Republicans support
unions when people have more buying
power you have a stronger middle class
and the rich do better to infrastructure
spending like the interstate highway
plan and socialism like the GI Bill and
a more progressive taxation rate the
rich have never paid lower taxes and
seventy years than today this is all
fixable man-made policies got us into
this income inequality mess and man-made
policies can get us out of it now so
it's not Jesus that's gonna get us out
look if we had a government based on
Christian values we'd be kind to the
poor kind to the sick kind of prisoners
and not start wars yeah there you go
well pretty much everything we ever do
on this show and everything you're
seeing in the news constantly all is
about money in politics so actually go
check out wolf dash pack.com all right
well more for you the New York Times has
put together a composite ranking of
where Americans are healthy and wealthy
or where they're struggling and let's
take a look at the graph okay so the
Times came to this conclusion by looking
at six data points for each county in
the United States and they included
education median household income
unemployment rate disability rate life
expectancy and obesity all right so
where are you doing worse the more red
or the more orange it gets
are the places you're doing worth so a
lot the South not doing that well
the tiny orange dot by New York City I
don't know if you can see it over there
is the Bronx so not doing that well on
the Bronx Northern California I was
surprised
not doing as well as I would have
thought now we're in SoCal over here and
we're doing okay
but again the South is by far the worst
the Midwest seems to be okay
Florida I thought was kind of
interesting because the beaches all are
in good shape but if you're in the
middle of Florida you're not doing too
well is there anything the middle of
Florida will be the beaches at hundred
years actually Miami by the time we
finish this show could be will be a
coral reef me finish this yeah exactly
notice right there that it's not the
highest concentration of doing worse
right in the heart of the voting against
our own interest belt okay so there's a
reason Alabama went for Romney and
you're looking at it right now yeah so
what's going on in that in that orange
area Lois can you gain I'm colorblind so
I actually can't see this map we'll just
trust me it's not doing too well in the
South Basin no I thought that criteria
is only interesting I was interested
that they included obesity in there and
it was unemployment obesity and I forget
what else was in there but it seemed
very subjective I'm always thinking
about these things in terms of like my
life cuz I'm a selfish self-involved
person so I was just thinking that like
in Los Angeles being obese is a lot
harder than I feel like it is in in some
of those blue places in the Midwest
right I'm just saying that was my
personal opinion yeah I'm with you do
you think there's a connection between
happiness and gay marriage because
apparently by that map it looks like
there's some connection the places where
gays are okay there's something what is
he okay I mean there's lots of states
where where marriage equality has come
about because of activism by a morally
awakened populace and other states where
a judge has just said no and whether you
like it or not so I don't I don't think
it's give me those crazy activist judges
we're always radically doing things that
are you helped people you're an activist
judge if you help corporations you're
strictly but I do think that that um in
many cases yeah you know in a more
progressive place where you have if you
if the people have brought about
marriage equality the same people have
probably bought about a higher
age less income inequality and therefore
more happiness it's why Denmark is much
happier than we are and why the american
dream really should be called the
scandinavian dream because they enjoy a
much higher standard of living of less
income inequality and you know no one
goes bankrupt ever trying to pay for
health care but a heart they not as free
as us isn't that they're more free than
us I know I'm just kidding yeah so wait
let's just throw the graph up for one or
a second because there was one that I
thought was particularly interesting
there Wyoming they're pretty happy in
Wyoming there's a 17 of them so Wyoming
hopefully if you if you need to look at
a map while you're looking at this to
figure out why the middle up I'd love to
see what North Dakota looks like in five
years because the fracking economy is
gonna change the entire economic makeup
of the whole state and you can go to a
place that was a one stop sign town a
year ago and make six figures now
driving a truck up there and fracking
will change the entire economy of North
Dakota right so you'll make a lot of
money through fracking but your water
might be exploding yes that could be a
press oh if you're if your water
explodes in your face even if you're in
a big fancy house probably wouldn't be
too happy you may be doing worse so it
might suddenly get better and then when
the exploding water comes then it'll get
worse there's so many of the factors to
factor into the Simmons it was a very
it's very interesting it just I don't
think it's a complete picture yeah it
means so Wyoming that's why I think
Wyoming's the interesting one because
there are so few people there yet they
seem so is that partly at their lands
Cheney's drop out of the race NZ so
that's why happiness has gone up there
that I could have Liz Cheney as their
senator I can't think of a possibly more
perfect way to end it John Lewis thank
you guys there Twitterers are right down
below and we will do this again next
week don't forget to comment like
YouTube that Facebook thing I love that
thing so plus their Twitter Instagram
Pinterest I love your show David screech
oh yeah I love having you guys on so
yeah we'll do it again next week thanks
guys